ربما حاز هذا الرجل على تعاطف كبير خلال
الحرب في بلاده لكن وثائق الاستخبارات
الامريكيه تقول انه يتمتع بغرائز عدوانيه
تتناقض مع صورته كرجل دوله هادئ ورصين
فالرجل وفقا للوثائق اراد ان يذهب في حربه
مع روسيا ابعد من حدود بلاده ليس فقط داخل
روسيا بل الى حد استهداف مصالحها على بعد
الاف الاميال في اجتماع عقد في يناير
اقترح زيلينسكي شن ضربات في روسيا واحتلال
مدن حدوديه روسيه تمنح كييف نفوذا في
المحادثات مع موسكو وفي اجتماع ثان اقترح
زيلينسكي هجوما على مواقع غير محدده
فيراستوف غرب روسيا باستخدام طائرات بدون
طيار اجت اخر عقد مع نائبه رئيس الوزراء
اخترع الرجل تفجير خط انابيب دروج
بالسوفيتي الذي يمد المجرى بالنفط واشنطن
كانت قد منحت زيلينسكي اسلحه متطوره
بمليارات الدولارات لكن بايدن رفض طلبه
بالحصول على صواريخ اتاكس بعيده المدى امر
قد يعكس صدقيه ما تتحدث عنه الوثائق من
عدوانيه زيلينسكي وفقا لاحدى الوثائق فان
المخابرات الاوكرانيه وضعت خطتنا العام
الفائت لشن هجمات سريه على القوات الروسيه
في سوريا باستخدام مساعده كرديه سريه
العمليه كانت ستفتح ساحه معركه جديده على
بعد الاف الاميال من اوكرانيا لكن امر
بالغاء الخطه دون توضيح الاسباب مؤخرا
زودت بريطانيا كيف بصواريخ ستوم شادو التي
تتمتع بقدرات التخفي ويصل مداها 155 ميلا
سرعان ما اعل ن الكرملين انها ضربت
الاراضي الروسيه واصابت
مدنيينسكي نافاميرا نيته ضرب الاراضي
الروسيه باسلحه غربيه بينما تقول
التسريبات انه كان ليفعلها وياخذ اوروبا
الى تصعيد جديد رائد المصطفى العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات